on va rester dans le sport fustine on va
parler alpinisme à présent et ça tombe
bien car hier se tenait la Journée
internationale de la montagne c'est
l'occasion de revenir sur cet exploit
que va tenter Delphine chéot
souvenez-vous cette professeur de PS à
tour s'est lancé un défi gravir
l'evverest en 2024 elle s'entraîne
depuis de nombreux mois notamment en
gravissant le pic Lénine en août dernier
nous avions suivi son ascension alors où
en est-elle dans sa préparation
désormais elle va nous en parler
puisqu'elle est notre invitée bonjour
Delphine chéot bonjour alors c'est
décidé vous partez du 5 avril au 30 mai
les billets d'avion sont pris ça y est
alors c'est presque 2 mois de mois c'est
le temps qu'il faut pour gravir
l'Everest toutit exactement oui parce
qu'il y a toute une période
d'acclimatation et en fait les les
ascensions pour ce qu'on appelle le
somit pou pour aller au sommet en
général c'est
mimé en fonction aussi des des fenêtres
météo voilà parce que on peut pas
grimper comme on veut tous les jours il
faut attendre vraiment que la météo soit
de la partie donc voilà il y a un bon
mois d'acclimatation et puis
aès on fait on monte on redescend on se
repose on remonte un peu plus haut voilà
on acclimate le le corps c'est un petit
peu en D tranquillement voilà alors je
le disais tout à l'heure vous vous
entraînez depuis longtemps et vous aviez
notamment fait l'ascension du piclénine
au kirgisistan oui et depuis vous êtes
rentré alors vous continuez votre
préparation comment alors je continue la
préparation alors en ce moment je suis
sur un bloc par exemple cardio euh au
mois de là à la fin du mois je vais
passer plutôt sur un bloc endurance
alors j'ai toujours en fait donc je
m'entraîne régulièrement dans la semaine
et j'ai toujours un un une dominante en
fait toutes les 3 semaines je change de
dominante et puis du renforcement parce
que effectivement ici bah il y a pas la
montagneou mais on arrive quand même à
se préparer euh voilà sans forcément
aller en montagne toute l'année voilà
alors pour partir justement vous avez
vous avez monté votre association qui
s'appelle à chacun son toit du monde car
cette expédition c'est aussi l'occasion
de mettre en avant que les femmes
peuvent tout comme les hommes gravir une
montagne tout à fait on était parti en
fait on est un groupe de quatre à avoir
construit cette cette association où on
est 241 adhérents à ce jour et en fait
effectivement on était parti du constat
qu'il y avait beaucoup moins de femmes
qui s'engageaient dans les gros
événements et notamment dans l'alpinisme
et que 14 mes qui sont allé au sommet
contre 140 hommes à peu près et donc en
fait on on s'était dit de par ce constat
il faut absolument qu'on qu'on fasse un
projet et qu'on montre justement notre
engagement cet engagement sociétal et
montrer aux femmes qu'elles sont
capables aussi de de faire des belles
choses al pas forcément on est parti sur
lesvess mais à chacun son toi du monde
c'est aussi créer son entreprise et
atteindre les
objectifs et les rêves et il y aura
aussi un volet plus écologique voilà
c'est ça on a un deuxième engagement qui
est un engagement écologique et
effectivement il y a quatre personnes de
l'association qui va partir du 18 avril
au 5 mai prochain et qui va partir en
fait faire un nettoyage de la vallée de
l'Éverest entre louclla qui est
l'aéroport le plus près du camp de base
jusqu'au camp de base donc il va y avoir
un nettoyage des déchets pour aider les
populations Paron sait que le Népal est
un des pays plus pauvre au monde et que
c'est compliqué pour eux voilà donc on
va aller donner un coup de main et ben
pour en savoir plus sur cette expédition
vous allez faire jeudi et samedi
prochain vous allez donner deux
conférences dans laquelle vous allez
présenter votre projet tout tout à fait
euh c'est aussi l'occasion de trouver
des messenes et des sponsors car une
expédition sur l'Everest ça coûte cher
hein 46000 € oui tout à fait ça comprend
quoi alors ça comprend le permis
d'ascension qui est à 10000 € déjà pour
me permettre de pouvoir accéder avoir le
droit de gravir la montagne et puis
après il y a une partie qui est reversée
aussi au niveau de l'État pour tout ce
qui est bah évacuation aussi des déchets
sur les différents camps et puis il y a
une partie bah pour le le guide charpa
qui va m'accompagner pendant 2 mois et
puis après toute la
logistique qui concerne bah nourr loger
pendant 2 mois alors que ce soit en
tente ou en refuge voilà toute cette
logistique
d'équipement de déplacement et cetera
quoi et pour assister donc je le
rappelle à vos conférences rendez-vous
les 14 et 16 décembre à larsay donc le
14 voilà ça sera pour essentiellement
pour les
commerçants et puis les entreprises donc
à 18h30 à la salle Margeot de larsé et
samedi ouvert à tout le monde au public
et ça ça sera salle François mitteran
voilà à larc à 17h les rendez-vous sont
pris merci Delphine ch d'êt venu sur le
plateau